Hello everybody.
Hi, hi, hi, hi, hi, howdy.
Welcome.
Hello.
Hello, hello, hello.
Guys, I'm trying to be good.
I was like, I'm trying to be good.
Oh, so I got food.
And after I eat food, like a salty food.
It wasn't even that salty.
Oh, music is good.
But after I have something, I want something a little sweet.
But I resisted.
I resisted.
Now I'm thinking about it.
I got bubble tea yesterday.
I should...
I should be good and strong.
I should be...
I should be strong.
But sometimes...
Is it the same for anybody else?
Where it's like...
I can have like a tiny piece of chocolate and I'll be like,
okay, that's what that's all I wanted.
You know what I mean?
Minto is our sweet treat.
Would have been said you chose to be evil and strong.
I think I could do it.
Ben and Jerry would like to have a word with you.
What?
What's wrong?
What did the hit mean?
A valid struggle.
Like, you know.
discipline eventually teaches your body.
I think is there something, I think there's something though
that's just like you shouldn't be craving a sweet after
every meal.
There's like some sort of issue with you.
If you are always, if you are wanting something sweet after
everything.
Maybe.
Sometimes though I'll get like the, the, the gummy.
Here's my, here's my life hack.
My Afterlife hack, you guys.
If you want something sweet, like a little treat, a sweet
treat, if you will.
If you want a sweet treat, then I get those gummy vitamins.
And then have that, and then you're like, yum, yum, yum,
yum, yum.
Delicious.
And then then you're then it's healthy I refuse to ever
learn moderation no Sango no only E1 wait but no the the
recommended value is two yeah like a fiber gummy you'll eat
them every day you're supposed to to take your vitamins
every day what do you guys mean i'm gonna overdose on them
it's i said
i said you have you have to do it once a day do that with
monster ultra like the drink oh geez oh wait sorry oh there
we go sorry but for some reason sometimes obs does not let
me look at dono's thingies um wait wait there we go you know
what else goes hard after a salty meal a nice crisp beer i
don't like the taste of beer i tried it i tried it to be
like my oshi and i didn't like it oh meantime i was like you
just got home from my damn heart they work but speaking of
sweet treats have you seen the gummy popsicles trolley mix
No, I've never seen those.
My older brother had to get his stomach pumped from because
of the Flintstones gummies.
Those are...
No, sorry, vitamins.
Those are not gummies.
I'm talking about a good gummy.
Candide, gumai, those things.
Wait, what?
What's wrong with the Flintstones gummies?
Are they like the Haribos?
Do not overdo the gummies.
It'll probably just pee it out, but do not slam gummies.
vitamins come on and slam and take your vitamin come on and
slam and take your vitamin come on and slam and take your
vitamin come on and slam and take your vitamin I tried to
get a chocolate mint chocolate mint treat earlier today but
they had only chocolate and made me sad to not have mint how
dare they Goodbye cruel world takes two one a day.
No, it's a one a day.
It's a one a day Yeah, I didn't yesterday for dinner.
I had salad I think I'm doing good beer gummies.
This could be marketing gold Well, they have gummies that
make you high.
So what if there's gummies that make you drunk?
Someone could invent it And that, wait, it's like those
chocolates that have the liqueur in them.
Wait, they exist?
Like a gummy?
Jello shots.
It's a little different.
That's a jello.
Not a gummy.
Not a gumai.
Little different.
Doc gave me vitamin D supplements.
That tastes really good, but there's so much vitamin D.
I'm only allowed to take one per week.
I took some, I took some, what was it?
It was like a hair, like a biotin type supplement once.
And it tasted so delicious.
Every day I'd be like, I gotta get my gummies.
I gotta get my gummies.
I don't have them anymore.
But I would be so excited.
I'd be like, I can't wait to take my gummies.
I need my gummies.
some yeah where can i buy gummies that give you anime power
right next to the in the in the in the in the pharmacy right
next to the gummies that make you turn you into a anime cat
girl
so you anime pop though but don't don't take them at the
same time don't take them at the same time five below i know
i was taking a daily vitamin d gummy did you know it can
cause calcium absorption that forms hard rocks in your
intestines no that's why i'll never take vitamin d i'll
never do it i'll never take vitamin d
is there an anime where you gain power eating gummies one
piece I finally got my fumo and it's so huge it's ginormous
no are there gummies to help me with my moi moi deficiency
deficiency sounds like someone's not watching enough minto
made mint channel wait one second hold on ah dog dog that's
right you can't handle carbonation I bet you'll enjoy a nice
melon soju then mmm melon watch
more monkey yes yes yes yes welcome guys to meltopia I'm
excited to play this because it seems to be like power wash
simulator but you're also just melting stuff you're melting
things and finding things i'm excited i'm excited a great
zatsu game where we can yap and melt and i fell because of
the the summer heat maybe some people would want a bit of a
cool down type game my brother had to get his stomach pumped
because he took too many made mid-channel gummies.
That's literally...
Did he take the recommended amount?
500 of them?
Shubbed into your mouth all at once.
You can chubby bunny play the chubby bunny game.
Chubby ballers.
But with with Made Mint Channel branded gummies.
Only one minto per day.
Or more.
Or the mostest.
Some people need gummies.
Brand Blade, welcome back.
Thank you.
I wonder, you know, it would be fine to do, like, food
stuff.
But probably...
Difficult also doing like densetsu gummies.
I wouldn't want my flavor to be melon.
Lots of regulations on food.
Pretty, uh, pretty tough.
Well, maybe raspberry.
Do to lack of!
No!
Wait, no!
I've got melons in the back, baby!
I've been about to send a super in a while, so I take my
$5-y news.
Joshua, thank you!
Were you able to get my fan letter yet?
From when?
From when, Joshua?
Was it an event?
Let me know.
If you sent it to the Denzatsu PO box, they haven't sent us
anything from that yet.
Some Denzatsu-shaped molds for people who want to make
gummies or chocolates.
Wait, that'd be so nice.
That'd be good.
Or like ice cubes and he can drown us.
and your favorite beverage.
Tensetsu cookie cutters.
What if we, what if, what if you use too much dough and we
end up really fat?
Fat and flat.
I kind of want to see it though.
I think it's, I love when cookies turn out really stupid.
When it's like, it's almost like the, the Sonic popsicles.
situation.
Like the rat cookie.
I mean those jazz vinyl records.
You have to sing some jazz first.
Speaking of gummies, there's a bag of open sugar-free
haribos on the table at this party.
Prayers for the unfortunate who consumed them.
Who brought that?
During the mean green AX, I was so nervous, I forgot to say
it was my birthday the next day.
Psychic Maniac, happy birthday!
Sorry, I'm a little late.
Happy, happy birthday!
I think, yeah, they did change the formula, though, no?
Of the Haribo sugar-free...
I almost said cookies.
Maybe I'll go get a cookie.
I'm so particular about my cookies, though.
the the Costco one I didn't like it I tried their Costco
oatmeal cookies I didn't like it very much too much sugar
not enough oatmeal but I like for chocolate chip cookies I
cannot have them unless they are unless they are what's the
word hot melted melted I will not have a crispy cookie.
Only, only.
That hotel chain.
Uh...
The general tree?
What is it called?
The double tree!
You guys gotta get your chocolate chip cooked.
from there.
Double tree apparently has has cookies that they give you
when you check in.
Need to try insomnia cookies.
Oh, I've heard of those before.
I have.
But I've never tried them before, too.
It sounds like such a college.
Such a college establishment.
I don't need a fire to melt my cold, dead heart.
Minto's cuteness does that for me.
a whole two trees double double them and give them to the
next person what if you'd said that they're like here's your
cookie and you're like double it and give it to the next
person what if instead of cookies they give you a tree hi
boys you look extra cute today thank you and i'll look even
cuter uh what day uh is it wait is it in a week one week
from today oh my gosh wait my my jacket is falling off one
week from today at my new outfit debut yuppie one week one
week quite scary wait it's scary I mean those colors are
great to look at on hot days it cools you down you're
feeling nice and refreshed i have this one spray that i
spray on me after a shower and i'm telling you you guys wait
hold on let me see if i can get this spray hold on the name
of it
no no it's thinking no no no okay it's okay i gotta find the
right spray though so i can tell it is a Wait, I wonder if
you can even buy it here.
I got it in Japan.
They have it on yes style, question mark.
No, they don't have...
Okay, I'm not going to tell.
Well, I can still tell you.
I feel bad, though.
Wait, okay, hold on.
Hold.
I got this because I needed a new face spray.
And I tried it.
And it...
I did not realize it was not a face spray.
This thing, like, it didn't burn my face off, but I was
seeing colors.
Okay, hold on.
So it's this brand called Metia.
Metia.
And I got the Animal Crossing collab one.
This thing.
If you are able to find this somehow.
aqua body mist cool day if you get this and you spray it on
you after after a shower i'm not even kidding you it your
you will feel frostbite it's great i was like i'm i I'm not
even exaggerating it's so intense if you find a way I will
also look into it and see if there's more or similar things
that you can get easily out of Japan out of the country what
do they call Animal Crossing in Japan they call it You can
see it a little bit on the packaging.
On the bottom.
Yeah, animal forest.
But yeah, I will see if there's another similar kind of
spray that is made with the same or similar thing.
Because if you really need a cool down, it's this stuff,
baby.
It's this stuff.
awesome so awesome not sponsored at all just don't yeah
don't use it on your face
don't use it on your face just your body i remember
surviving last year in tokyo with these mentholated cooling
wipes oh yeah those are quite popular you can find other
cooling sprays in japan and typically they do a pretty Good
job.
The ones that I've tried.
But this was another level.
This is another level.
What about the armpits?
Only if you are ready for your arms to freeze upwards.
And you'll be showing your pits to everyone.
And it'll be so embarrassed.
And you'll be like, oh man.
Why did I spray my armpits?
And now everybody can't stop looking at my armpits.
Like that.
yeah you could take off like a plane exactly shall we melt
new game let's start
use a shovel for digging a holes thanks for the tip game hey
bozo my gosh i love when game tips whoa
whoa why do you hate him We're going into Meltopia.
Wait, why did we rob him of his...
Of his wood.
Ooh, the sound of the footsteps in the snow sounds so good.
I'm colder already.
Whoa.
Whoa!
Oh my god!
Oh, it melted everything so quickly.
We're gonna be able to speedrun this game, I think.
Wow!
Aurora Borea!
Upgrade my stove.
Ay.
Okay, I think it's telling me to do other things first.
Oh!
I got an- I- you found an artifact!
Bring it to the stove to melt the ice!
Dang, that's- It's my melting gun!
Melt gun.
Find the melt gun.
We have alien trade- Not, uh, robot- Traders!
Trader Joe's over here.
What are these?
Oh, more artifacts.
Anything in there?
Spooky?
What's in here?
Oh, more.
Whoa, I'm so short.
I'm very small.
Everything in here is...
There's a little bit of screen tearing.
Let's see if we can...
fix that.
I'm stuck.
Maybe if V-Sync enabled will help?
Oh.
It actually did.
Very nice.
No motion blur.
Was there a motion blur set?
Oh, I'm so sorry.
Let me turn that off.
I did not even notice.
Open sesame.
Wow.
Why are these not artifacts?
They're pretty darn cool, I think.
Huh.
Gun, shoot gun.
Rup.
me when when the slightest cold front comes in and you can
see your breath outside
we're gonna have to oh wait i'm starting to get cold i think
i saw i saw it in the corners so we can't upgrade anything
yet let's go What is this?
Upgrade gun.
For $10?
I'm broke.
I have nothing.
Next tool.
Huh.
And what do you have?
Warp.
I can buy warmth.
Oh, look at this greedy guy over here.
I have no money.
What is this?
There's so many little things.
that i've like this looks like a bomb for real
what is all of this go fast travel oh find other mine cards
okay fill energy
and buy items i can't i literally cannot i'm getting cold
again though maybe i need to okay in here is nice and warm
let's go Let's not waste time.
Wait, what's this?
Cell, normal.
Oh, interesting.
Oh, now it's warm in here.
Can I set the place on fire?
No?
Not yet.
It said use the shovel to dig.
Oh, it's broken.
Oh, this is where we go.
There we go.
I'm melting.
Ooh.
Oh, it's kind of sad.
Oh, I found resources.
Recharge my fuel.
Oh.
Thank you.
I wonder if it's unlimited.
Oh, I'm stuck in here, aren't I?
Oh.
This is not... The little rope is nice.
My inventory is full.
So here we sell items.
I got 26 bucks for this junk.
Upgrade your melt gun powers.
Alright, you don't have to tell me twice.
Circus of value.
So now my gun is going to be crazy mode.
I know this is kind of out of the blue, but how do you feel
about Snoopy?
Hey, Snoopy!
I've realized lately he's one of my top three cartoon
characters.
Snoopy is a great choice for a cartoon character to like.
That guy is so funny.
Snoopy has so much...
He's such like a...
He's such a...
He's such a bastard.
He's like a lovable...
little guy who's like so you know there's something you you
hate him and love him and stuff love that guy okay it's
gonna be hard not to clear literally everything you know i
found new resource new resource oh my gosh fuel critical oh
um do i sell my stuff all right we might need to we might
want to upgrade again soon
nice oh this is this is so satisfying oh my inventory is
full already
so it doesn't look like it wait can i if i shoot this then
no it went something it does not crave the fire upgrade
again this looks relaxing it's quite it's quite nice guys
it's quite nice and now we have more fuel too yeah what can
we buy here warmth an inventory seven to 17 that's pretty
huge fuel tank glow sticks dynamite
Oh yeah, oh yeah.
What else will we find in here?
Apparently you're trying to find, or rather, you can get
some sort of, uh...
What's the word?
Some sort of fossil or something in here.
You can buy UOs, exactly.
Fuel is critical.
here.
I'm excited to go deep, deep in.
I don't think this is a horror game.
you'll find Matara Khan.
Whoa.
Matara Khan in here.
The world's oldest fossil ever.
I learned something cool about Sandhill Cranes.
I learned recently that they're one of the...
We can get it.
They're one of the oldest living birds and so they haven't
evolved in like two million years or something crazy like
that which
you know it sounds like a long time which it is but also I
think like what it was a wait it might have been like no I
think it it might have been was it 2 million or 20 million
that's quite the difference but because i compared it to
horseshoe crabs those guys have not evolved in like like 50
million years wait sand hill crane evolution oh it was 2
million okay i was right oh let me get warm I'll just get
some energy while we're at it.
Auto save it.
Two, three, two.
Yeah, I'm gonna do, I'm gonna disable that.
Uh, don't do that, please.
Never, thank you.
Okay, all right, never, thank you.
Yeah, yeah, that was a fair auto save, for real.
Let's do more on my melt gun.
75.
Upgrade the melt gun three times.
Don't forget to save.
Look at the ice in the midair.
I wonder if there's anything in here.
Oh, yeah, there is.
Oh, it's going to be really hard not, like, melting
everything around.
You don't...
Dang, we're really...
Whoa!
This is melting great now, though.
Like, wow.
fuel is critical we can make it we can make it come on grab
me a couple more things dang it come on come on mama needs a
pair of new shoes we are speed it is it does it does kind of
bring out the power wash simulator in me though wanting to
get rid of everything you know but also my urge to explore
is even stronger.
Oh, yeah.
We are...
Oh, wait, my inventory's full.
Sandhill cranes are so funny to me, because everyone loves
seeing them at the zoo, and I'm like, these idiots stop me
from backing out of my driveway.
That being said, the little chicks are adorable.
They are very cute.
I don't...
Don't ask me why.
I was...
I mean, you can.
I was just curious.
I was just looking up like Sandhill cranes, and...
to find them and like they're kind of like they're migration
patterns and stuff just like i don't know i think sandhill
cranes are very fascinating you know so i was just looking
up about them and stuff inventory full already but also
you're looking at a at a two million old creature that's
huge no
like that's really crazy I think oh guys we're getting that
we're going in deeper we're going in deeper I wonder how
much damage the dynamite truly does wait I hear something I
hear an artifact I think oh you guys hear it how
does the crane live for two million years honestly humans
are just a skill issue or and like let's get more fuel and
what else should we buy next maybe more inventory and warmth
warmth is not so much an issue right now but it will be once
we get in way deeper you know I
hear it how's the audio by the way
we're so close we're so close there it is we found an
artifact I like the music in this game.
Gotta turn it up just a tad.
A bone.
Oh my god!
Oh!
So loud.
Wow.
That was awesome.
We found that.
We found that good, guys.
Good job.
That was great.
No, no inventory full.
We'll just keep melting until we can know more.
I wonder if there's like, you know, we're following this
path.
But what if there's other ones?
What if there's like little ways that we didn't even know we
could go?
me in here.
Well, my warmth is going quite down.
You would think it wouldn't because I'm I'm... I'm standing
next to fire.
I'm gonna keep selling.
I'm gonna grab all this stuff.
I think I got everything.
Inventory flow already.
I wonder what happens if you run out of warmth.
I imagine you might like blackout or something and then
revive from your last save?
That is my guess.
Oh cool.
I want to upgrade my gun.
We shall next time.
Can we save and try?
Sure.
Are you sure you want to save the game?
I'm sure...
Oh, thank you.
Well, what if we just keep going?
Well, I'm sure we'll die at some point, though.
I'm sure it will happen.
Naturally, organically, in nature.
We all die sometimes.
We're really clearing this up, though.
Are you a ghost that lowers the temperature when you show
up?
What do you mean that all ghosts do that?
No, I might be.
Isn't that the best?
Don't you want to be haunted in the summer?
That's why, like, in, like, Asian countries and stuff, they
tell ghost stories in summertime because they're like, it
sends a chill down here.
It makes you nice and chilly.
We're dollars!
Alright.
Now I'll save and we'll die.
But it's so hard because...
Ooh, that looks like an eyeball in there.
Wait, that's creepy!
What is that?
Oh, it's just floating ice.
There's even more up here.
That we've missed.
the sounds sound effects are very satisfying in this ghost
stories are free air conditioning I was watching something I
was watching something it gave me chill there was like it
was like some ghost thing and I was like oh wow that ghost
did a good job speaking I want to do better with my ebps my
electronic voice Phenomenal.
The music changed.
Why did the music change?
Are we getting deeper in?
This is a pretty game, all things considered too.
New area, I guess so.
We're so frozen in here.
Why don't we just wait until summer?
Wait.
wait let's let's fill it up and then I think we can make
this like a new little base a breakthrough yeah oh but I
needed enough they should have a thing here oh yeah yeah
whoa here's one too Yeah!
Oh, neat!
Oh, I get it, I get it, I get it.
The snowman.
I get it.
Oh, I opened it the wrong way.
I got a hundred bucks!
Let's go.
There's more in here.
Oh, I get it.
I get it.
You're right there.
I know.
You're right here.
Oh, there it is.
The voices are getting louder.
Like, hey idiot!
Stove part.
Whoa, what does that do?
What does it do?
Upgraded stove.
We have so much money now.
What if we do it again?
I have eight bucks to my name, but...
Worth, I'd say?
I'd say...
Oh, and my inventory's full!
We can even sell more.
Yes.
Let me see how much it is to upgrade my inventory.
150.
Okay, we're close.
I bet there's more in here we haven't even gotten.
Oh yeah.
Oh yeah, we'll just clear out this area.
Make it nice and clean.
They really shoved some stuff in this snow.
Like pretty well.
That looks mostly clean, huh?
Yeah.
Much stronger.
Is this open too?
What was the difference between...
Oh, this is...
What's the difference?
Yes, more, more.
I like we have two different ways we can go.
There's so much in here.
Holy cow, there's so much in here.
And it's like such a small little room.
That's like, it's very easy to grab everything.
Holy cow, there's so much in here.
So much loot.
We'll just walk in and our inventory will become full again.
It's weird how much of a delay there is before your
inventory count updates on the hood.
We're just too good at the game, honestly.
We're just speed running like crazy.
We're focusing all on attack.
My bad.
Build a max.
Great
time!
We can.
We can get it next time.
That'd be pretty good.
What's like an interesting random...
I talked about the Sandhill Cranes.
What's a random interesting factoid that you've heard
recently?
I'm dying to hear.
I would like to know.
I also want to go into that crystal area because I feel
like...
Maybe there's...
Maybe we can't quite go through it yet because we don't...
Aren't able to get through it, but I'm still curious to try.
I learned that boogers are called bogeys.
British.
They are.
Did you learn that from the podcast?
Did you learn that from the Den Setzu page?
Trion podcast?
How very interesting.
Apparently at AX the smaller vendors don't get to decide
where their booths go.
I think that's for a lot of conventions, actually.
Minus tone.
C is read the exact same way in Japanese Onyomi and Mandarin
Chinese.
Wow.
I mean, I guess that makes sense, huh?
Because let's do...
I want to try the dynamite.
Wait!
Okay, yeah.
I have whatever this is.
Maybe this is a glow stick.
And let's do inventory upgrade.
I want to see this other place, though.
Was there anything here?
I'll just clear it out to ease my curiosity, you know?
There's gonna be, like, one boot.
I knew it.
A pipe.
Oh, you can't jump and spray at the same time.
Interesting.
The scientific name of the common thresher shark, allopias
vulpinis, can be translated to fox-fox, and it makes me
irrationally angry, as an old-time I mean, zoologists.
Do I blow this up?
Does it work?
I'm afraid to waste it.
Fucks, fucks.
I wasted my only one.
It's a good sound.
In fact, I did learn until too late is The guinea fowl I own
likes to peck at my window at 5 a.m.
to wake me up.
I still love them, though, funny birds.
What a little jerk.
I would like to get a bird, but they are so...
I want to get, like, one of those cute, like, what are they
called?
Um, like, uh, I think they're called African greys, I think.
The cute ones that you'll see in videos that...
uh speak and do fun things like apollo yeah yeah yeah like a
like a parrot bird
glass but i i'm not ready for the commitment i don't think a
lot of birds outlive us i mean i'm dead anyway so i don't
know how that would fare for me and them But, like, my uncle
had, uh...
My uncle had, um...
The really colorful ones.
Oh my gosh.
My brain is...
I didn't get much sleep last night.
I had a...
I had a nightmare.
I had a streaming nightmare.
But I haven't had one in a very long time.
But, um...
Let me see.
Yes, he had a couple of macaws.
And, uh, those guys live up to be like...
Oh, we found another cool room.
They live to be like 50 or something.
Macaws, those kinds of parents will live a very, very long
time.
What is this?
A hook.
Whoa!
Spider-Man.
Very nice.
Anything else in here?
Oh, oh, oh, oh, I got the achievement.
Find the hook.
My, um, but yeah, my uncle had a couple macaws.
One time, uh, he got a call from the police.
And they were like, sir, we need you to come back home.
Or something.
I don't know how they got his number.
Maybe they asked, like, his neighbors.
But it's because the neighbors heard someone going, help,
help, help in his house.
Were they screaming like people?
They absolutely were.
They 100% were screaming.
Oh wait, I think...
Let's get some more warmth.
We're kind of...
And we can do...
Another inventory.
Bird behavior.
Yeah, they're apparently extremely loud.
And just like that.
I had some inventory here that I did not pick up yet.
We'll grab the rest of the stuff and then we'll grapple
upstairs.
...
Wait, is this a...
Is that a hole to go into?
Maybe not.
Oh, almost looks like it, right?
I had a cocktail growing up named Sir Poops a lot.
Then it laid an egg, so it became...
It became amber.
The reputation changed.
What the hell?
It never stopped!
Why?
I mean, I don't think you had to change.
Oh, wait, we can buy things here.
I'm so silly.
If we want to buy anything.
I don't feel like a name change was in order, you know.
I found the way.
But there was that other area, too.
Very curious.
Very, very curious.
Oh, gosh.
This game is dangerous.
not wanting to like i want to clear out everything
she found de way
is knuckles de way like one of those i don't say i wouldn't
call it a persisting meme but is it one of those that like
you think it predates like when memes just really just
started to die and you know what i mean like nowadays it's
kind of like, uh...
It's hard, like, you know, memes die in a month.
It's not that old.
It's pretty old.
It's pretty... It's pretty dang old.
I don't know what to tell you, buddy.
It's pretty dang old.
Let's try another dynamite.
And also...
Let's try up here.
Oh!
Attachment failed.
I like the tutorial for this.
Oh.
Scary.
Wait, what about to there?
Really?
Okay.
Can I has cheeseburger?
We'll never die.
I'll never let it exercise it from the grave.
Can I has cheeseburger?
Oh yeah, let's try and upgrade the hook.
so true I didn't even think about they did say like other
tool huh so far I'm very much enjoying this game so far it
feels really good are you guys being
satisfied oh my heat or my we're They're so small.
My warmth was pretty low there, though.
I find it a little faster.
Let's go maybe upgrade some stuff.
And then we'll dynamite.
We'll dynamite.
Let's see.
Oh yeah, wait.
Maybe we can't do our hook.
No!
That's so lame.
Let's do some more fuel.
I want to uncover everything.
What if there's many more bones than bones that we realize?
More than the mammoth bones.
Wait.
Oh.
Oh, oh.
I was going the right way.
Kind of get...
It's easy to get lost in the sauce in here a little bit.
Who was littering?
How many...
I feel like we should be finding human bones with the amount
of shoes I've found in here so far.
Let's just keep going forward.
Onward!
Following the path.
Parkour.
We can go backwards from here.
Fuel levels are critical.
It's about done.
It's about over.
It's about over for me.
Okay.
I just lost a bunch of souls.
But don't.
Oh, we're gonna parkour, you guys.
That's exciting.
Oh, I forgot to... Wait, we'll dynamite.
We'll dynamite so that I can grab a bunch of stuff.
It's...
Do I even need to?
Maybe we wait.
I mean, there's still a good amount in here.
Not a lot of good...
Or not a ton of items.
Or snow, I mean, is what I meant to say.
You're one dynamite gal.
Wait, what's that reference to?
Wasn't that something?
Wasn't that...
Toy story?
Wait, what was that from?
I think you can refuel with R.
Yeah, but I only kind of want to do it in, like, an extreme
circumstance.
Wreck-it-Ralph!
I knew it was some Disney movie.
Dang.
Guys, ah.
The new...
Okay.
I have to complain a little bit about Disney matters.
About Disney-related things.
And I'm really sorry.
But as a theme park enthusiast, I'm very passionate about
this topic.
And so did you know that the original Pirates of the
Caribbean at Disneyland was one of...
What was it?
No, it wasn't one of Walt's last projects, but it contained
real skellies, like real human skellies in the ride.
One of my favorite things about the Pirates of the Caribbean
ride...
is that it does not like, it's very like mysterious.
So basically the way the ride works is like you start in
modern day.
You're sailing, you're sailing, you're sailing the ocean
blue.
And then you come across a bunch of like pirate skeletons.
And you're just like, oh my gosh, how did these guys, how
did they die?
Like what happened?
What's their story?
serious very excitable to go through but in this new they've
recently re added like a new thing to the ride where disney
has started doing these fugly projection face animatronics
and literally nobody likes them no everybody i don't like
them they're so ugly they added one to the pirates of the
Caribbean ride where he like it's it's one of the skellies
or rather it's like what used to be the skelly that used to
be there was a skeleton sitting on top of a pile of gold and
now what they and it was just very like you know very creepy
very mysterious and then now what it is is a guy with like a
cartoonish looking being like holding up a piece of gold and
then he turns into the skeleton what they're trying to do is
handhold feeding you the story of of the what happened how
he died but nobody nobody we don't want that you know that's
a valid grudge but it's so ugly I hate the projection Yeah,
where's the intrigue?
Exactly, exactly.
We want the mystery.
And they were just like, nah.
What if you find out that he was greedy and took a piece of
gold and it cursed him into being a skeleton?
And I'm like, that's, we already got that story from how it
looked before.
You could already tell that's what happened.
Guys.
It's upsetting.
I'm upset.
Imagineers hate imagination.
These gosh darn modern day imagineers don't know what a good
thing is.
Alright, here, let's parkour.
But I'm scared of mine.
Oh.
I didn't get a running start.
I'm scared of my warmth.
I gotta do it fast, I guess.
Wait.
Why am I doing this?
There's stairs.
Wait, there's literal stairs.
On the other side.
Why did I do all that?
To feel cool?
Maybe?
I'm just going forward to see if maybe we can hit another...
Oh.
Oh gosh.
Wait.
I'm stuck.
Okay, good.
Hit another room maybe.
Wait.
Uh-oh.
Is that blood?
Wait, I'm...
There we go.
We gotta get out of here.
Not because of the blood.
My toes are cold.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Chill, hey.
All the people that died in peak.
Um, I have $900.
Let's see.
We could do more fuel.
We could save up for the big melt gun.
Let's do more warmth, more inventory for now.
I think that'll be good.
I have my dynamite.
We'll do that.
We'll do that into the hole.
Yeah, we'll do the flamethrower upgrade after this now.
But since we're going to a brand new area...
Whoa!
Sick.
Nice.
Nice hole.
There's so much here.
Gotta make sure we can get back up though.
I guess we can if we, uh, if we use the thing, right?
I'm just following this, I'm following this guy.
Oh my god, an actual dead man!
$200!
What's that?
Dynamite.
Is that for this?
Thanks?
We found a fast travel!
This is huge!
Guys, this is huge!
What's here?
Too chilly?
Triple chill, triple chill.
Buy dynamit.
What?
Is that what his head?
Huge!
We're saving up.
First stop, baby.
Nice.
What else is in here?
didn't get everything here yet.
We have not got everything here yet.
All the stuff here.
I guess kind of the idea is once you go down, you're not
going back up.
Because they don't make it easy on you.
No wonder that guy died died down here.
One way trip.
Yeah, pretty much.
He should have bought the upgrades!
I'm not trying to shame the guy, but he didn't play the game
very well, probably.
Just saying.
Some of us are gamers.
Some of us are skellies.
Wait.
Maybe he tried.
Get good skelly.
I'm so sorry that you died.
Oh, okay.
It's not a total one-way trip.
I'm like, I'm actually peeling like a loop goblin right now.
I'm scrounging for any last.
I'm like, yes, oh yes, please.
A pipe.
A shoe, a boot.
Anything.
A dumbbell, please.
You
want to become a skelly one day?
Don't let your dreams be dreams.
Honestly, to be a dancing skelly would be so fun, probably.
I don't blame you.
I do sort of want to buy a dynamite.
Let's do this again.
Oh.
This works.
There's so much in here.
If we're trying to get a big upgrade, we do want every
little thing that we can get, though.
What's something that I want to do?
I want to go on one of those euthanasia roller coasters.
I could tank it.
Everyone else is just weak.
Whoa.
You guys have never seen those before?
They're like designed so silly that you die of cringe.
It's just like, oh my god.
But no, they're like, if you wanted to die on a roller
coaster.
And, and, you know, this would be, it would, it like, shocks
your system into death.
Aw, man.
Wee.
Where is this legal?
Uh, nowhere, probably.
Probably not quite.
I'm not donating my body to science.
I'm donating it to Disney so I can be propped up in a spooky
ride.
I wonder...
Oh my gosh, imagine.
It's just like...
Put me in a ride that will really scar the children.
Put me in a ride where I can really make a difference in the
atmosphere of the ride.
Small world?
What's wrong with small world?
If you could design any theme park ride, what would you
make?
Honestly, I do want...
like a haunted house roller coaster like a legitimately
spooky roller coaster i don't know how though because like
roller coasters are too fast and haunted houses are meant to
be slow and enjoy the in the atmosphere i don't know i just
like themed rides i'd be happy with anything
hall of president star big fight home I'm the president!
Come on, you can get him.
Yeah, yeah.
Okay.
I think I'm done with that area.
Ultimate chill.
Whoa, it's cold!
I feel cold playing this game.
Is anyone else?
Yeah, that was fast.
save great idea you're my auto save auto save will happen in
three two one breaks your game breaks your game breaks your
computer the g-forces of that kind of roller coaster are no
joke your heart can't pump enough blood into your brain and
you just pass yeah yeah you pass out so it's like it's like
a quote-unquote more humane way because you just you just
pass out and die those euthanasia coasters I once almost
blacked out on a regular roller coaster with a tight spiral.
Nixie!
Wait, that's dangerous!
Make sure you hydrate and eat before going on an intensive
roller coaster.
You guys!
If Disney put your maid cafe in Disneyland, where in the
park would they put it?
Put me smack dab in the middle of the...
Pirates of the Caribbean ride.
Actually, Indiana Jones.
Wait, how much was it to upgrade my gun again?
Was it 1,500?
Yeah, I just spent $100.
Oops.
I want the inventory upgrade, too.
I feel cold, but I think it's because the vent part of the
air conditioner is under my bed.
Or there's a ghost in your place.
Fire in the hole!
Oh, I forgot that I went in even deeper.
My bad.
Wait, where'd the ribbon go?
I'm lost?
The ribbon stops here.
Where'd the ribbon go?
We're gonna become a skelly too.
Oops, our...
Oval instead of a circle for us.
for a good reason.
Oh!
Treasure chest!
I got $300!
Let's go.
You'd be in a, it's a small world with the rest of your
kind.
Oh it's here!
Wait there are branching paths now!
Oh shoot!
We're gonna get so lost you guys.
We're about to get, like, mega lost.
It's a small world after all.
It's a small, small world.
I'm going to sing it so that it gets stuck in your head and
then you're upset.
Upgrade the milk gun to the maximum.
Oh, this is the max we can do, really.
Oh, okay.
These are glow sticks.
Okay, good to know.
Let's grab another dynamite.
I want to go to a theme park right now.
Okay, so if I...
Let's see.
If I do F, like here, how long does it last for?
Whoa!
That's bright.
Use a flashlight.
is what it said.
Does this feel like it's...
Oh, oh, booty.
Does this feel like it's better?
Whoa!
Someone's home?
I don't know what's going on.
Ice cube!
What?
Can we...
Okay, good.
We can fast travel with it.
Ice cube!
It's a mammoth part.
Oh my gosh, it's the other foot.
It's the other foot.
I'm gonna turn it down, jump.
Mint starts singing Small World Ice Scream in the voice of
Jeremy Irons.
No, no, anything but that.
What do you have against small worlds?
I wish I could get like a magnet to collect things more
easily, you know?
My inventory is already full.
I should have sold it while I was there.
I rode a roller coaster once and forced my eyes open during
a loop, but the lack of blood to my head made me lose vision
for a few seconds.
I think that's only happened to me once.
I don't dislike loops and rides, but I only care about drops
mostly.
I like that tummy pit feeling.
I'm a big fan of that.
Feeling in my tum-tum.
You hate that feeling?
I'm a bit of a psychopath with it.
I don't...
I live for it, even though I'm dead.
If I were...
If I could be alive for it, I would be.
It's cool seeing you with those sloppy sister- I don't care
to be dead alive kind of felt.
Like I have one foot in the grave being there at both of the
Hollow Eden lives.
It's totally worth it though.
Chocotaku!
I'm so glad!
I'm glad you came to see us!
I hope you had fun!
Thank you!
There's lots of stuff here.
Scoop it up, scoop it up.
This does last though, this does last.
Good to know now.
So if we do need like a Hansel and Gretel our way home, we
have at least the light that points to the direction we need
to go to.
Top 5 roller coasters go.
Fujiyama at Fujiq.
This is not going to be any order, I think.
I really actually liked Manta at SeaWorld.
New room, new room.
What else?
Oh, new resource!
New resource!
Huge!
Ghost Rider!
So much fun, yeah.
Notsberry.
I love that one too, actually.
I feel like screaming at the top of my lungs.
It's a snowball!
No!
Do it.
Sing at the topest quarter of the universe.
I can't believe this doesn't make you warm.
Uh, oh here.
I haven't been on Top Gun.
And I'm very sad because I missed it when it was like, you
know, actually Top Gun.
Oh, we have 590.
Hold on, let's see what we want to save up for.
I could do more fuel.
I think inventory might be our biggest thing right now,
though.
Inventory is a big save.
Since we have the...
Let's do fuel.
And then we'll save up for inventory.
There's a Top Gun roller coaster.
There is!
And it used to be themed after Top Gun.
But then I guess they lost the...
As it goes, they lost the...
the rights for it to use it I feel like that didn't do much
huh I feel like that didn't do a ton yeah the licensing so
it's not it's I think it's still called top gun but it does
not have like the theming of it anymore unfortunately yeah
pretty wimpy for snow right that's what I'm thinking Gosh,
there's a lot here.
Okay, we're going to clear as much as we can before we go to
the next area.
Before we go to the next area, I'd like to go with an
improved inventory.
So...
Oh my god, it was a loop!
Well, crazy work.
The game, the game.
Kajambu does it again.
The game got us good.
We manifested it.
Did we?
Guys, when is the World Cup until?
I'm just curious.
I hope everybody is enjoying watching it.
I heard some like crazy game happen the other day I think it
was with Argentina or whatever one more week one more week
it's been fun yeah oh wait I'm saving up we're saving up for
for not fuel for inventory huge comeback yeah that's what I
heard like they scored like five goals or something in the
last Top Gun is called Flight Deck now.
It was actually the first roller coaster I've ever ridden.
Give me nightmares for days.
It should be fun riding.
Should not give you nightmares.
It's funny because I'll go on any roller coaster.
Some...
There's a new one coming out that looks terrifying.
I can't remember where it's coming.
where it's like being built at at the moment it's called
like project purple or something if you look it up um
basically uh i'll ride anything but motion i get super
motion sick from like vr rides and things like that i can i
can do any roller coaster feel fine Any motion VR-type ride
will have me pukin.
I hear a special...
Ice Cube!
Which is weird because I'm typically okay with VR itself.
But VR rides...
It's mainly...
The ride will be, like, moving.
And there is this simulation of...
movement, but there is no air.
You know what I mean?
Like, what is this?
Place it on a pedestal.
It says a pedestal.
Where?
Which what?
Does it... Oh, place that hard hat here.
Here?
Okay.
Meltopia?
It's been three times I've watched a stream, and I feel like
every time they feel like lucid dreams crosshark thank you
put it on a pedestal not that pedestal this pedestal not
that pedestal that one over there not this pedestal that
pedestal I wish we could find a way to sell items like far
away how did you you miss the big floating green sign?
How did you miss this big floating green middle finger, eh?
Take that!
Get it because I'm green.
Where?
I think we left a lot of stuff in here.
So let's just grab it.
Inventory full.
If you head back, you sure it's not pink?
You're more of a sea green.
Yeah, really?
I always thought more self, more of a mint green.
A mint green.
Wouldn't that make sense?
Okay, we might be going, like, kind of back and forth for a
minute.
collecting a ton of stuff and then selling it.
A ton of stuff.
Yeah.
I guess the orbit green never noticed.
At the meet and greet at Anime Expo, someone came up and
asked, Why is your name mint?
I never really thought about it.
I never really quite thought about it.
You know, the answer I gave was when a mommy and a daddy
love each other very much.
Alright, at least I'm not named Sephiroth or something, you
know.
Naruto, Boruto.
Where are, raise your hand if you're a Boruto baby.
Where are all my Boruto babies at?
Oh, is this another It is!
Oh, I thought it was a loop.
Wait.
Oh, there we go.
There's so many branching pathways now.
Minto is Minto because she's cute, cool, she's cute, she's
cool, she's cool, and cute!
Not me.
Nah, you're a trip trip, baby.
I think now we can buy the inventory upgrade.
Ugh, never mind.
I'm a liar.
Kewal.
She's so cute, guys.
Where was this entrance?
We did have some new materials here.
Maybe I've already collected them and sold them, though.
Where am I?
Everything is... I'm lost.
Oh, but it was out here.
It was out here.
Items are just falling from the ceiling.
My mommy and daddy didn't love any of us enough to name us
Mint.
Don't... No, Tuna!
They did!
It's just... My parents were trendsetters.
They knew that it was going to be a hot commodity name.
$506!
Okay, so the new stuff is worth more.
Nice.
They were trailblazers.
Exactly.
They knew what the hot stuff was going to be, the hot new
hotness names and all.
A psychic told them.
My mob did actually take one of my sisters too, a psychic
once.
Psychic was like, your kid's gonna die!
I don't think...
I don't know if they're allowed to do that.
Maybe you shouldn't...
Maybe there's some things you don't say.
Wait, there's like hooks here and stuff.
Hmm.
Did they die?
I don't know.
Okay.
We'll find out next time on Dragon Ball Z.
I want to find new places.
I'm ready to find new places.
The inventory is already full!
Where did the...
Oh, it stops here.
Okay.
I think my...
My glow stick did eventually run out, unfortunately.
It appears.
Psychic, you say.
You took aim my joke!
No!
No, what happened?
Could the triple cold place have anything good?
High risk, high reward?
What we can do is...
Wait.
We can save and go in, and if we die, we die.
I'm just gonna save over.
I had a teacher who had the same thing, went to a fortune
teller as a teenager, didn't pay for the extra service.
She got told she was gonna die.
She wound up super scared for a while because of it.
That's so rude.
YouTuber devourer of jokes.
Found a new resource.
Oh, it's like mega...
Wait.
I didn't find any new resource though.
It's just like super, super snow.
Full of high valuables.
Come on, we can get it?
I can, maybe?
Okay, I'm going back.
Chado bot found you and brought you...
Oh, I'm shivering.
All my stuff!
No!
My money, my big money.
Thanks a lot.
Why couldn't you pick up the goods?
My favorite Dragon Ball Z episode when Vegeta went to Akiba
and destroyed Reformed Lloyd or... Okay, Reformed is...
was not Reformed.
There's some of that special snow in there too.
Oh yeah, we could load back.
Wait, let me see if it's still there.
It could also be there again.
Maybe they dropped it on the ground.
Oh my god, we're gonna die.
For that, he takes all your resources.
Oh, I had nothing.
Bozo.
Yeah.
Get scammed.
I had nothing on me.
Oh.
Oh, there we go.
Let's save scum this bozo.
Yeah, you know what?
I will load.
We'll go in there another time or something.
Because when you leave, it like entirely...
Like, it's so strong.
So we'll wait till we have more warmth to go through.
It's like super strong in the beginning, like that beginning
area.
Because the wind is blowing on you and stuff.
so we'll just hold off for now yeah but there were those
items we were able to get
I can't even tell where I am anymore so crazy
I guess we could keep following the pathway let's do that
and get big bucks from all the stuff in here this stuff is
worth a good amount Yeah.
Yes.
The music is good too.
Guys, what's new in Minecraft?
I was listening to some Minecraft music earlier and I was
like, I don't recognize the soundtrack anymore, you know?
I was just thinking like, what's going on?
on in Minecraft now.
I know you can, like, ride gas and stuff.
That's pretty fun.
They added sitting.
Without a mod, you can just sit!
Wait, which way am I?
Wait, which?
Oh.
Sitting on the gas.
Yeah.
Sit update.
With cushions.
Oh, that's pretty cute.
It has gotcha now!
No way.
You're pulling my leg.
Where did those...
Where did this all come from?
It's just on the floor.
Wait, we could get more warmth, actually.
I should get more fuel, though.
So we'll start...
Ooh, ooh, let's start getting fuel.
people in here just lying for fun you guys wouldn't lie to
me are you lying
don't do that Santa won't bring you presents if you lie
everyone knows that
I wouldn't yeah you shouldn't you wouldn't and you shouldn't
oh we're going we're going our own way we found another
pathway this though where does this lead to Tesla we can
open that thing now oh neat
whoa shut up guys we can sell our items here and fill our
energy here this was huge this was huge
Oh, this is the special one.
Does it do anything?
Oh!
Oh, yeah, we're going to need to get more resources.
Holy cow!
We're Teslaing it?
New resource.
Feel critical.
It's okay.
That's okay.
It's right here.
Wait, we could dynamite this even.
I feel like I didn't get that much.
Oh, because my energy.
Let's fire in the hole.
I got a boot for $3.
Wait.
How do I get back there?
This is the... Wait, what's the difference?
Is this the special kind?
Wait, this is a mine cart.
This is a mine cart way.
Is this the special part?
I can't tell.
I guess it is.
We want the fast travel.
Because we do still need to go back, unfortunately, for...
Um...
For upgrades.
I think the...
Tesla kind of sucks.
This is ice, too.
Why is all this stinky stuff in here?
Nice amount to sell there.
Nah.
This sucks, though.
It's not very good.
I mean, I know it's a tough ice, but...
Dang.
I wonder if dynamite does much.
We got $11.
We got nothing.
We should be able to upgrade it though.
Because...
Because it said like on the upgrade thing it was like item
1, item 2.
So I think we will be able to.
We'll head over and try.
But I have to go find them.
I want to get the mine cart.
Let's try.
Let's see if we can get it.
Maybe.
Somehow.
Okay, wait.
Why does it feel like it's better at the moment?
Suddenly feels decent?
Yeah, I guess we need to get close and personal, right?
Am I at the top?
No way.
What?
Oh, oops.
For somewhere?
I don't know at all anymore.
We might have been, we might be getting bamboozled to be
honest.
It definitely said, it definitely showed a mine cart and
said in here.
In here, in here!
See?
I'm not, I'm not making stuff up, I'm not trying to be
crazy.
I'm just confused.
It totally dies.
And a minecart over here would be huge.
Wait, I'm stuck.
Wait, I'm actually... Oh, there we go.
This...
Way.
Draft my eyes to save me.
Did I actually find the way?
Oh my god, please!
Yes!
Just enough!
Oh my god, we did it.
That's where we went.
Oh wow, that was crazy.
We almost didn't make that for sure.
I made 10 bucks, baby.
We'll do fuel.
It was absolutely worth.
Oh gosh.
Wait!
Yes!
Yes, the Tesla is $2,000.
make this a little bit easier to get through.
I'm not going to waste my time getting all this stuff in
here, though, to be honest, because a lot of it's junk, I
think.
Yeah, like $1.
Yeah.
So we want to go into here.
But there was also more stuff around here.
As we saw before.
Wait, what's this?
Oh, yes.
I was...
Did I find that though?
Yeah, look at that.
$7, $10, $15, $12.
The high value items.
And what we need.
I hear another something.
No!
I was gonna say, please be a treasure chest.
Circus of value.
Oh my gosh.
You're a little inconvenient.
Ice cube.
Can we pause?
I gotta go pee?
Yeah, me too.
party break everybody wait oh this is tough yes install it
on the stove shall
we all take a party break together wait let me sell my
things yes 37 though I still feel like I want to upgrade
this thing
okay let's go pee
see ya
guys there was a little baby spider in my sink and i saw him
earlier and i was like hey little guy i'm gonna wash my
hands around you so that you don't get sucked down the sink
and i thought he would have been gone by now he wasn't no
someone someone i i didn't see what you said but something
about about oblivion and if it was about this song reminding
you of oblivion me too
he got sucked by the water he did he did yeah so sad
Stop right there, criminal scum.
I miss oblivion.
We could try this again.
But I feel like it's no different than being in here.
Like, it seemed like the same stuff.
Maybe if you go really far in, you get, like, Buku Bucks,
but...
Hmm.
This also seems like maybe a loop.
There must be one in there.
This had good stuff though, no?
12.
18.
It's kind of hard to walk through though.
You gotta like kind of dig the ground.
Hope you get something good.
12.
18.
Not bad.
I already feel like this is worth it.
a bit better though.
But the other area, we were getting it much faster, no.
I think.
Sometimes it farts a little.
If you hear it, it's not me, it's the Tesla.
It's not me.
I promise.
You can't blame the Tesla.
I think, in fact, I can.
Yeah, we aren't getting much items.
It's a...
I already got O'Carry get out too.
Sigh, guy.
Thank you.
You spooked me.
Thank you so much for the pink.
Don't know.
What sucks about this is it is like good.
Expensive stuff, but not a lot of it.
So it's a little rough.
What's down here?
Oh, more.
Let's just...
follow the thing it's also much slower 25 25 dollars nice
yeah
it does it's like more frozen in there too right we are
pretty rich I'm not gonna lie we're what why does it feel
like I'm making more well I know I'm making more money but
weird didn't feel like I had that much wait where's the
where's the ribbon oh it stops no where am I supposed to go
this is how this is how skellies are made in the caves I'm
gonna get reduced to a shape in here
have you guys seen those those cave diving videos but
they're like they're there's cave diving videos that are
like like uh explaining what happened in the nutty putty
cave and things like that and then there are cave diving
videos where there are parodies of the of the ones that do
talk about the actual cases and there's one where it will be
like he fell down a hole and did not realize that there was
somebody in there doing bad stand-up comedy when he laughed
Two boulders came from the left and the right, smushing him
entirely.
The...
The incident reduced him to a shape.
So reduced to a shape is like a bit of a cave diving meme.
It's so funny.
They are really funny.
Have you seen these boulders lately?
Once the kneel with boulders.
Part of me, I don't know.
Recently, I was, like, inking.
Or inking.
I was itching.
I was not inking.
I'm not a squid.
I was itching to watch Seinfeld again.
I don't think people realize that I watched all of Seinfeld
before.
It was funny because, like, I like Seinfeld.
And, uh, when I referenced for the, for the birthday karaoke
stream, oh, nice, our ribbon is back.
Um, I referenced a red letter media joke, the Dick the
Birthday Boy t-shirt.
And some people were like, does she know?
I guess, you know, I can't expect people to.
watch all of my...
Nice!
All of my streams all of the time, but it's funny because I
feel like I've been very...
Look at this whole very open about my enjoyment of red
letter media.
But some people just don't know all of them.
I was inking.
Yeah, you were.
Thank you for the super chat.
We knew you knew.
Yeah, of course, I know.
You guys probably know.
Some people.
Red Letter Media mentioned.
I love Red Letter Media.
Though I haven't had a chance.
Oh, what is the last one that I watched?
I haven't had a chance to watch them so much recently.
My favorite Seinfeld character is Murphy.
It's funny because I'm sure there are people out there that
are like, oh, she knows George Costanza.
Not by name, but she knows George Costanza because, you
know, there's Murphy.
Hi Murphy.
Murphy in her chat using that guy as his profile picture.
But also, I just know George Costanzo.
Because of the show.
Oh, okay good.
Sometimes I get stuck.
Oh, like now?
Other times I just gotta force my way through.
We are not making...
Okay, I'm give up in here for now.
And we're gonna go back in here.
And we're gonna make mega millions.
We're gonna make so much money in here.
Because it's like a lot of the same stuff.
We can just make a ton of...
We can just get tons of it really easily.
We need lots of cash.
Like we need to fill up our inventory.
We're not doing it with the stinking Tesla.
It's too slow.
See, this is so much more satisfying.
The game was very satisfying until, like, we had to switch
items.
Now it doesn't feel so good.
Yes, almost $1,000 worth.
Nice.
It no longer scratches your ink.
It does not!
My ink!
Yes, I'm inking!
I'm inking!
Yeah!
Where was this?
Oh yeah, all this right here.
Where is this leading to anyway?
Let's keep going down the road.
Yes?
I hear it?
Somewhere?
Below me?
Oh!
500 dollars let's go oh but it is a dead end sadly so once
we get all of this we're like we gotta go back into the the
icky stuff
thank you
after we clear this area too we can go back and upgrade a
few things probably and feel a bit better about things maybe
like this is still has many much to clear yes
yes it feels good feels good to melt it wouldn't there be
like so much water in here now I'm thinking about it like
wouldn't where's all this ice going you know I mean wouldn't
we be drowning in by now Oh, it's like evaporate.
It would be moist.
What was it?
I learned recently that like...
Uh...
On like Arctic and Antarctic expeditions.
Way, way back, you know.
They, uh...
They had to be careful about...
They had to like hold their breath when using binoculars
because otherwise if they didn't their breath would would uh
would like cause condensation uh on like the rim of the
binoculars and it would their eyes would stick to it and
like and when and they would it would rip their skin yeah
isn't that crazy think about you never there's some things
that you're just like oh my gosh like i never would think
about that being an issue because of my daily afterlife like
i'm not going out in the arctic every day and doing stuff
like that yeah new meaning to keep your eyes peeled truly
right i can't even imagine the pain this sucks
Being an Arctic explorer sounds not fun.
Pretty bad, actually.
That's when the eye cups came in for it, I guess.
Yeah, now you know, right?
You can be like, dang.
This is here to keep my eyes from gluing to the binoculars.
Thank you, modern day inventions.
their lips would freeze to together overnight too oh my gosh
everybody would wish to be a snorer huh guys we're almost
done with this area no i'm not ready for the for the big
bucks to be gone that reminds me of the historical fiction
book i think you'd love called the terror I do love me some
good historical fiction something else in here no way
another treasure chest with 500 more gold wait where I just
oh I just went this way I found it that's more blood is is
it not or it's a reflection of me huh am I wearing like a
red suit or something
Great one.
Really?
Several people are recommending it.
Huh.
The terror.
Is it set on a boat?
This is probably meant to give you a leg up on your Tesla
upgrade so the transition isn't as hard.
Probably.
Maybe we will focus on that then, huh?
Because otherwise, it's like...
It's pretty rough.
It is a pretty rough...
Different.
Really?
Nothing in there?
That was such a huge chunk, though.
I think we're just about done in here, then.
Sometimes these bits can be pretty sneaky.
Alright, let's...
Oh, I'm getting cold, too, though.
I think it's based on a doomed Arctic expedition.
Oh.
like all of them no they're arctic expeditions are so cursed
though let's head back we have seven thousand dollars to
work with we're actually rich and we are going to upgrade
baby
our base is so beautiful Whoa.
Ah.
Isn't that warm crackle?
Thanks, I made it myself.
Wow, you're very talented.
Oh wait, no.
We're not going, we're doing this.
Yeah.
Upgrade.
Fuel?
That's rough.
It's such a, like, Wait, that's a huge upgrade though.
For the fuel?
It like absolutely devours fuel though, it's kind of crazy.
Very expensive weapon.
On your opinion, which is more scary?
The Arctic or the Antarctic?
I guess it depends on what you qualify as scary.
I guess more of the Arctic is explored than the Antarctic.
Try the Tesla on normal snow.
But for some, for animals, the Antarctic has leopard seals,
and those are horrifying.
Oh wait, we're not going this way.
Even getting to Antarctica is crazy, right?
Go through that Drake Passage, baby.
Okay, this is not as bad now.
It's a little more manageable, I'd say.
Okay, this is good.
This is good.
This feels good.
Much better than before.
Still not nearly as many items in these parts as the other
ones, the regular snow, but...
We're not almost out of fuel in two seconds.
We will save up though for the fuel, next fuel upgrade.
Which I think we have now?
Or was it 1900?
I can't remember.
Okay, that's the sound we like to hear, right?
The loot
ASMR.
This game has a great soundtrack though.
I'm a fan.
So far I'm a big fan of this.
My tiny hole just made for me?
My little hole made for me.
Wait.
Oh, we haven't got any further.
Is this not the one that we...
I guess not.
Remember we had another hole made for us earlier.
Oh, wait.
Freedom?
Hmm.
What is here?
Gamers don't look up?
Or they do?
And it's...
Can't tell what's going on?
Uh oh.
We're gonna freeze again.
Why is it going down so fast?
Holy cow!
Let's, um, save.
I don't want to die.
I don't want to die!
When I went to the bathroom, I forgot to get more water.
I wonder how the dynamite works on this, though.
I can't imagine it's that great if it wasn't super great on
the other stuff.
There's like something glowy over here.
Oh, this guy.
Is this what they were mining?
This ore?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I think it's funny because I think your warmth goes down
when you run and like it goes down faster but wouldn't that
make you warmer you think I will try a dynamite
the sweat freezes is that really a thing is that really if
so that's kind of crazy Maybe we can grab, we can like clear
this up too.
Since we're right here.
On your clothes.
No, wait.
Did I, I clearly, I don't think I dressed for the, for the
season in this game.
That's their purpose.
It's a very dangerous thing in cold weather.
Yeah, sounds like it.
It's hard to see in the blue.
snow too but it kind of looks like like a starry night so
it's really pretty this game is so like aesthetically
pleasing i'm a fan i'm a fan
fuel critical fuel critical fuel is always critical
okay if we could um keep going Which we will.
But also...
Hmm.
We'll clear up a little bit of this area as well.
Maybe we'll find, like, a passageway or something.
Something, something.
No!
This thing is...
Just devours my fuel.
What if this game became...
a horror game out of nowhere.
Don't tell me that.
Wait, does this go anywhere?
They shouldn't, right?
It doesn't...
I don't think so.
No, okay.
It almost looked like a second passage for a second.
It does...
It has like a bit of a...
Like a bit of a crevice.
Good luck with the Here's something for me forgetting to use
your code when ordering flavor powder just a moment ago.
Oh, thank you, Varo.
You're totally good.
You are all good.
I hope you enjoy your flavored powder.
But if anybody is ordering from Gamer Sups, you can use code
Boomer.
me.
My code.
We want to help a ghost out.
Okay, boomer.
Boo!
Oh, new place.
We found it.
This looks a little...
This makes me a little nervous.
I guess we can always...
Oh, actually.
Where are we going, though?
Where are we going?
We do need to get more...
gosh I'm like we need more warmth as well wait
oh here it is I got lost for a second oh no you guys are
gonna die we're gonna die uh oh we're gonna die we might die
for real wait I'm running I'm running I'm running I'm
running I'm running I'm running oh we made it holy cow I
thought we were gonna die for real holy cow I thought we
were gonna die for real.
That was a close one.
Maybe this game is a horror game.
They're not gonna make it.
If I do fuel... Dang it, we're so close!
We're so close to warmth.
We can do this we can do this.
What if I go in here?
What if I just find some stuff in here?
I feel like I cleared, like, all of this area, though.
What was in here?
Oh, the grapple.
Nah, it's just better to go back, I think.
We could try this.
Triple cold!
Just grab some stuff real quick.
Take it back.
Oh my gosh.
Please, please, please, please.
Full bait!
Thank you!
Full bait, mom.
Thank you so much, brother.
Give me the fire.
She'll be warm for him a night.
Give...
Wait.
Set a mint on fire.
She'll be warm for the rest of her life.
I mean...
Maybe.
Okay, we're back to normal.
We're back to normal.
That was crazy.
We barely made it.
We barely made that.
That's crazy.
Okay.
Do I have enough money?
I didn't even make enough.
That's embarrassing.
I'll be back.
That in there is too dangerous.
Let's see if there's any...
Sorry, anywhere else in here.
That I didn't finish up.
Oh my gosh, the Tesla actually sucks on normal snow.
It doesn't even work.
Haven't used the grappling hook.
Haven't really had a... Oh, I guess I could have used it in
there, huh?
I was gonna say I haven't really had a reason to use it, but
you don't really need it just for...
Just for going up in the air.
Yeah, it does, like, just, like, do Spider-Man around.
Anything, anything.
Anything.
Uh...
Anything, anything.
Seems like it's faster.
Yeah, I think so, too.
I think you go technically faster, I feel.
Oh, wait.
I'm trying not to get too far away from the mine cart
because then we can go back and we can upgrade.
But I feel like I've gotten...
I feel like I've cleared a lot of this area.
Oh, wait.
There's some items that I hadn't picked up yet.
I did a pretty thorough job, I think.
Yeah, I did too thorough of a job.
Wait,
I think I have enough now, though.
Wasn't there something you could use the Tesla on in the
first main base?
I think so.
I think I know what you're talking about.
area that we I think I had opened it up let's see it might
have been in here actually no let's go back oh I remember I
think wait do I remember was it over here I
remember it but I don't remember where wait is right here
21 buckaroo let's Yeah,
this will be a nice, easy way to collect some cash for a
bit, I'd say.
Yellow ribbon.
Interesting.
There's just not nearly as much stuff in here, which sucks.
For legal reasons, I have to remind my fellow chat that you
should not attempt to ignite your ocean.
To explode wildly.
Party.
Because it's a party foul.
nothing else no other concerns about it but just don't do it
food thank you so much for the pink thank you thank you
thank you
awesome okay we were getting we're good on inventory so yeah
warmth is huge at the moment we might even be able to get
another upgrade of it faux pa is a faux pa to set you other
people or your ocean fire it's just like a social it's an
anti-social activity only people who don't follow society's
rules i mean you could rebel and set a little you know dear
me don't fellow eyeballs please send your prayers to my
friend on his hasn't gone pot hasn't gone potty in four days
wait you know like there's like ways to kind of help there
right you mean like number two
that's really not good though it's your friend okay it's
your friend okay
there's like stuff at the convene you can get um uh i've
never tried this method i've only seen about it so I can't
try it myself because it involves a fizzy drink but um okay
hold on I'm gonna try and help you out I'm gonna try and
help you out but four days might be might be too far gone
okay so they're at the combini in the uh in like the vitamin
area there is a drink it's a green drink with a yellow cap
if I remember correctly with a lemon on it okay you get that
it's a drink it's a fizzy drink then then you get one of the
one of the cognac drinks in that same little area one of
like the jelly cognacs and then you get a cup of ice that
they sell there and then you pour the fizzy drink into the
ice cup and also put the cognac into the ice cup and you
masee, masee, masee, masee, masee, masee, masee, masee and
then that should help a little bit.
This is for anybody who struggles with going to the
bathroom, number two, in Japan.
There, I hopefully will help you out.
That will hopefully help you out a little bit.
I don't know.
Oh my god!
Eat Mike Tarsons' ass!
Well, look who decided to drop in!
Thank you so much for the raid.
Thank you!
I can't stay up to...
For the gift.
Rising Glitch Face, thank you!
Oh, whoops, um...
No, yeah.
We're saving up, we're saving up.
What was it, 2,200 we need?
You got four!
Thank you!
Where's that?
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Okay, barn, thank you.
Something light.
Will hear dark soul with a lie.
Is that what you meant?
Now, well, thank you.
I think I found the drink.
It's called Yuzu Extract.
Let me see.
Legal reminder, High Riders, if you want to use a
suppository, you are obliged to play Overdrive whilst
applying it.
Legally?
Take over, thank you!
Wait, Yuzu?
Yuzu extract.
Not quite.
Hold on, let me see.
Konbini.
I don't even know what it's called.
Uh...
It's like a vitamin C.
drink typically you know you drink it to get lots and lots
of vitamin C it's like not ah I found it I found it I found
it I found it I found it I found it wait uh hold on save
it's this one on the left the
that one that one pretty sure almost positive like i said i
haven't i haven't tried it myself it's a sparkly drink so i
can't have it this has been poop tips with dr minto yeah and
then cognac is like fiber so but that's 1300 milligrams of
vitamin c baby this is a crazy hack big enough of a problem
that people go to Japan and can't poop afterwards.
So I'm here to help out as much as I can.
I don't quite know why.
I'm happy I did not have this issue.
Listen, you go to the convenience, look for the Tororo.
It's made from grated yams.
It works.
Trust.
vouch I can't vouch for it but Jordan is saying so perhaps
it will maybe from experience again mine is not a personal
personal experience but yeah
we help if We help each other, the fellow, we help our
fellow iBoo's out, right everybody?
Mid stink!
Why?
I'm memboot so I can have access to this emote while sending
this super.
I really like the way you say we are we.
It activates my almonds.
This has been on my mind a while.
Oh, Zonderman, thank you.
I like that you like the way that I speak I
just say words nothing special about it I just say words
we haven't gotten a mammoth block in a while have we now
this seems like quite the extensive game though are we going
down I guess we're going down
Good shape, it was my birthday yesterday, I'm finally in my
20s.
Cause Big Speed, you baby, you baby.
Happy birthday!
Happy Boppy!
Happy Boppy.
Yeah.
I don't know, sometimes you guys like the way I say things
and sometimes you're just like, ha ha ha.
What do I say that you guys think is weird?
Uh...
Uh, Jaguar.
Sometimes you guys make fun of me for it.
Which is it?
Yes!
We can upgrade something.
I'm embarrassed to say things sometimes.
Should we do more warmth or should we do more fuel?
Probably.
Warms.
I think.
Bullies.
I like your funny words magic my hand I wonder where we're
going in here
Jaguar reminds me of my grandpa what does that mean why am I
reminding you of your grandpa
oh sonny oh sonny you're you kids in your your jaguars I
don't understand
Wait, I'm a little concerned that I'm actually not going to
be able to get out of this place.
Oh wait, maybe we can.
Come on, come on, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Dang it.
Wait, how do I get out actually?
Over here?
I'm stuck.
Oh, the ribbon!
Oh!
There we go.
Nice.
Oh my gosh, we're almost...
It's a good thing we got the heat upgrade.
Holy cow.
Don't change your pay mind, Minto.
Stay golden.
Okay.
I do get embarrassed, though.
I get embarrassed.
Where did I find...
I found the ribbon here, yeah.
if i could i can't my booty is too thick for to get through
where will we go where will we go we got to get out of this
sometime right
oh we got out of it oh
we're about to die guys oh shoot yeah where
my 400 dollars like a warm memory take the compliment okay
okay
we gained yeah
yeah baby
i believed where were we before i think i remember
Uh...
Through here.
We need a map in this place.
It's crazy big.
I think we're trying to find like a way through here or
something.
Through here.
And we go up or something.
I'm actually gonna see if I can find a...
ribbon that leads us anywhere.
We go up here.
Oh, we went through here.
Okay.
Save?
I guess we should, huh?
Let's go back.
I'll go back and I'll save.
Actually, I'm lost.
Wait.
No, I'm not.
Yes, I am.
I'm...
No, I'm not.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay.
Saving!
That's when I say you're cool.
Thank you!
We're so close to, like, going back around.
We're so close to finding another camp that makes this
easier.
We're so close.
are everywhere unless
this is a dead end wait is this a dead end it can't be no is
it really I can't be no
she's like an ant a moth drawn to the to the snow no Oh no!
No!
I gotta go back.
Shoot, shoot.
I'm stuck, I'm stuck.
I'm lost.
Right on thing, now that the end screen has the lizards, is
the letter collect-a-thon officially over?
Uh, probably, uh, because I actually, I forgot to save
the...
I forgot to save the layer that...
Uh, or like the the file that I made them on.
So it would be a little tough to add new ones.
Whoopsie.
But, um, yeah, it was just for, like, a temporary thing
anyway.
Yeah.
But thank you, everybody, who contributed, so.
Thank you.
Alright, so we're not going to go that way.
I guess.
We'll go this way instead.
Oh.
Okay.
I lied.
I would like to dig like a little bit more obvious of a
path.
It has to be this way then.
Wait, I'm more of a danger!
Wait.
Thank you so much for the longest time.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
How do I get down?
Wait, wait, wait.
I'm gonna read it.
This way.
I'm gonna go back.
I'm gonna go back and read it.
I'm gonna go back and read it!
I was like, I hit my share a little bit, but last year I
lost my job and wasn't doing great boy you need to watch
your stream being so lucky to me you at events and meeting
ivus made every day worth getting through and as a five days
ago on my birthday i got a job offer
congratulations happy birthday let's go so proud of you
Yeah, baby!
Hello?
Q?
There we go.
Yeah, baby, that's what we like to hear.
I'm gonna put...
A thing here.
There we go.
This is not just a wall.
It can't be just a wall.
This can't be, right?
No, there's no way.
I do have to go soon.
Not go, like, as in, you know.
But I have to head back or I'll freeze.
I'll freeze.
I'm gonna freeze.
I feel like it takes me long enough to get here
that oh my gosh it takes me so long to get here that
it is impossible to get any work done otherwise I'm gonna
freeze you know
currently eating a super sweet watermelon perfect on these
hot days watermelon is a great snack it's just water so it's
like you don't feel guilty with it you know or not just but
you know it's a lot it's like mostly water so it's awesome
it's so awesome and delicious water everybody hydrate am i
going the right way am I?
Guys, I have no idea where I am.
Is this a separate path?
No, I'm dumb as bricks, man.
Sorry.
Sorry for my stupidity.
Can't wait to see you at Smash!
Yeah!
Oh my god, this weekend!
Didn't win the lottery for the Meekery.
No!
on all the super adorable dino merch.
Yeah, it'll be so fun.
See you there.
And there will be, there will be the panel.
So at least you there.
Hopefully.
Oh gosh.
I'm so lost, you guys.
I'm like getting so lost.
Please let me live.
Oh no, I'm gonna die.
I'm gonna die.
I don't know how I lived.
Holy!
It was at zero!
Maybe because I was right next to the room?
Holy cow!
Whoa, that was quite a throw, huh?
Nice.
Alright, this way.
This way.
What a thrill!
I wish I could get like, you know how I have the refuel, I
wish I could...
I wish I could get a heat fuel, you know?
Like a little heat pack or something.
I hear it.
I hear you?
I don't know at all where it is.
It sounds like it's on my...
I don't know.
I gotta go back.
I'll get it next time.
I never feel like I'm going the right way in here.
It's stressing me the heck out.
Wait.
Did I... I missed it?
Use the hook 50 times!
I could go get more...
Actually, I could go get more heat.
I'm going to go upgrade my heat.
I want to upgrade my fuel.
But I think heat is more important.
We can't.
If we are.
If we run out of fuel that's fine.
But if we run out of heat.
It's a much bigger issue.
So I think I just did a heat upgrade too.
I think that was the last one that I did.
It is.
Yeah.
Oh 27.
That's not that bad.
27.
700 is not that bad.
More heat.
Yeah, it's been rough.
We've been living on the edge for real.
Whew, whee.
Okay.
I wish they could give us a flash light.
Uh-oh.
Oops.
I didn't mean to use that.
Can I throw it in here?
Oops.
Alright.
We're back in, baby.
I'm gonna leave another one right here.
Otherwise, I literally can't see where I'm going.
Why didn't we realize we were so close?
Or so far in, I mean.
Didn't feel like we were that far in.
Feels like it's on my left.
Maybe it's below.
Ah!
$1,000!
It opened through the ice.
Don't worry about it.
We're just super strong.
We have crazy buff arms.
That's how I'm able to grapple myself and do all these sick
moves.
I'd never even imagine.
Where do we go, though?
Oh, maybe this way.
Oh, shoot.
Just notice my...
Please.
Grapple.
Sometimes I'm clicking it.
Like, crazy.
And it doesn't do anything.
Ah!
Let's go...
Was it?
What was it?
20...
I can't remember.
Game saved.
Let's get some stuff right here.
I feel like we're never going to be able to upgrade again.
I say let's get some stuff right here, but there's nothing
here.
What the hell?
The game is a troll.
There we go, something.
$12.
Let's go.
27.50.
Okay, so we're a little off.
Here, let's grab in here, then.
Fine, I'll make this hole bigger.
Ugh.
This is like, like I said, I do wish that...
I mean, it can't go super fast all the time.
But the downgrade to the Tesla is terrible.
Yeah, the next gun upgrade, yeah, is like 7K.
It's so rough.
Wait, we can go get the upgrade now, the heat upgrade.
Eh, eh, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Since we have time and
about to spend our money.
We'll get the staircase here.
We'll get all this here.
Yeah, we'll clear up this a little.
We'll make this a little bit cleaner.
Probably was bothering some people for a bit.
The cold never bothered me anyway.
Let it go, let it go.
I need more cash let it go let it go more cash oh
we're toasty we're toasty the most relatable song.
Call Jerry G, Whiteboard, 877 Cash, no!
I have a structured settlement that I need cash.
Who else remembers this conversion?
They went crazy though.
We're almost max warmth.
I don't feel like it's enough.
We have one dynamite.
I'll try using it.
Actually, I'm going to clear up this part too a little bit
more.
So we don't have to, like, bend around so much, you know?
Let's clean up these areas a little to make them make travel
a little more tolerable.
Millennial knowledge.
No, my name is Mint.
I know, it's confusing.
They both start with M's.
I miss when commercials were crazy catchy.
It's probably, there probably still are.
You probably just don't see commercials.
You know?
You probably just aren't seeing commercials so much.
Who's watching TV now?
Is it mint, minto, or minke?
Call me minke.
Everyone calls me that.
Call me York.
Taking up a new identity.
There's one channel near me that played those J.G.
Wentworth ones within the past couple of years.
I don't watch enough TV to know what they still do.
That's crazy.
They're still playing them!
That's nuts.
okay we're gonna blow it up
please do something oh that did do something a little bit
please ribbons anywhere ribbons please ribbons please and
I'm also gonna F right here gonna F off okay Oh my god.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, you guys.
It's another.
Okay.
We at least found something.
More eyes.
We found... No way.
I can't believe there's so much ice in my ice game.
Why is there so much ice?
Oh, that's the one I threw.
Why is there so much ice in my ice game?
Alright, I'm gonna save.
But it's so far.
I feel like they can't make it too long.
You know what I mean?
Like, it's so far away that making it too long of a of a
area would be like cruel you know what I mean just put the
ice in the bag man I don't get paid enough for this that's
such a lie I can't even make that joke so I was trying to be
a minimum wage like worker at Wendy's
Minimum wage, ice melt over.
The trauma.
Oh, you don't know trauma until it's a...
Until it's a midnight shift at Wendy's.
Okay, we're getting nowhere with this.
Actually, a lot of jobs.
I'm sorry.
Ah!
Oh, shoot.
We're in trouble.
I'm in danger.
There was also a thing to dynamite.
There was a thing to dynamite, too.
I remember my midnight shifts at Kinko's.
Not fondly.
The only...
I feel like...
And correct me if I'm wrong, if you have a different
experience.
But I feel like the only good jobs that are like...
a midnight shift job are the ones where you don't have to
deal with people you know if you have to deal with people
it's just like oh my gosh but if you don't have to deal with
people if it's like a quiet something you know then it's
seems like it might be pretty nice
getting pulled into the void so scary
I don't know.
I feel like we should go this way.
We lost so much heat already.
So much warmth gone.
We just gotta go.
We just gotta go through.
We just gotta pull through.
Oh shoot.
I hit a wall.
We just gotta pull through.
And hope and pray.
I hit a wall.
I'm stuck.
No!
Down, maybe?
It's over for us.
Oh, it's so over for us.
Guys.
07.
I wonder if we died in that one area because it was like a
freezing freezing area, you know?
Like a three freezing area.
Maybe it don't actually die immediately.
Maybe we were...
Maybe we have been...
Wrong about it a little bit.
Why is this like blinking?
Maybe we've been wrong about it.
Whoops.
Oh no, I didn't mean to click that.
There we go.
Okay.
energy is full i'll buy another dynamite just in case i'll
buy another two
and i'll have a fuel tank just i mean we need more heat than
anything else noon to midnight was the best shift i ever had
back at the day the folks who were midnight to noon had it
rough though yeah you know see that's what i similar to what
i had though but yeah maybe there's a shortcut you haven't
found i don't know i don't know there's gotta be that
hallway is a death trap it truly is right it can't be that's
what i'm saying it can't be that like that deep of a tunnel
because otherwise like they know they're setting you up for
absolute death oops that's not what i meant to do
It's so far.
So far away.
Stop.
I'm stuck.
Let's try it back in here.
Somewhere.
No way, man.
No way.
Unless it's like behind me.
Unless, wait, wait.
We might have found it.
Just keep the- Oh, yes!
Yes!
I saw flags.
Come on, come on.
No way.
I'm not gonna- You guys are gonna kill me down here.
Oh.
Holy cow!
Yes!
Oh, what is that?
Oh, we did it, you guys!
We did it!
We, like, brute forced our way through.
Holy cow.
What is this, though?
Nice use of refill.
Thank you.
I'm glad I got it.
I had an extra one, but I was like, I'm just gonna try and
go through it, you know?
because otherwise we definitely wouldn't they probably want
you to do that you know
i hear something
fast travel is this special snow or is this regular snow oh
this is the strongest snow that's not snow that's a rock Oh,
that's not what I meant to click.
Thank you.
What the?
I can travel to cold zones!
Oh my god!
Yes!
We're at the...
Wait, that's a second stop.
How many stops are there?
Wait, let's go to second stop.
Feels so awesome being awesome!
Found a new resource.
Oh Big money, big money.
Oh big money.
Yes!
Ice cube!
So you didn't miss any rest points they intended for that
super long run.
They probably, like I said, they probably were like you're
supposed to...
Maybe...
It's an...
It's an upgrade.
It's supposed to like refuel and keep going, but...
I don't know, sometimes it felt too risky, you know?
It felt too risky.
I wonder what upgrading the stove does.
I wonder if it makes, like, your general heat go down.
Less?
Or let's do this.
I'm almost tempted to do more fuel even.
Yeah, you get money for upgrading your...
For upgrading the thing.
It's awesome.
Let's see.
I feel like because we just got the warmth, more warmth, I
feel like almost getting more fuel is even better.
Save up for the Tesla.
You think he'll get a new gun soon?
That'd be sick.
Was that the, no.
How much longer am I gonna keep playing?
I'm actually wondering that myself.
because I'm enjoying it but I'm also getting kind of hungry
for dinner so we reached a pretty good stopping point I'd
say this is like a really great like kind of just pick it up
as whenever I feel like kind of game so though I am enjoying
it what's for dinner I don't know yeah what should I have
for dinner.
Watch out for dinner.
Anybody having a good dinner?
That's where you will let me possess you and then eat your
dinner for you?
Yum yum yum.
Tacos!
Enchilados here!
I'm coming over!
Yeah!
Prepare your body for the possession.
Do you guys see how much money we're making?
Just casually doing this all the way also look how much like
our fuel has how much fuel we've had and our heat and
everything i haven't even been paying attention to it it's
just that good our fuel is critical before our heat is
critical oh wow we might actually be able to upgrade the
tesla than we expected finally we finally things are
starting to uh um like the increments are good where wait a
second where was there a way to sell over here or no maybe
not we made a big progression hump by reaching that suit
right so awesome Where can I sell stuff?
I can't even remember.
Let's just go to the main hub.
1700, baby!
What else can I upgrade?
I think my heat, I could if I really wanted to.
Why not?
But this was fun.
I hope you guys enjoyed this.
as well.
We'll definitely pick it up again another time whenever I
feel like it.
I'm very curious.
I feel like I mean, there is so much to this game, no?
Because we got two bones of the mammoth.
Two out of the entire mammoth.
Like, this game has so much going on.
You wishlisted the game!
That's so fun!
Thanks for the streaming, Yeah!
Does this game have multiplayer?
Not that I can see.
But it would be great with it, wouldn't it?
No.
Oh.
Definitely a super chill game.
And also not chill sometimes.
Chill and also terrifying.
This has been a chill stream.
And more ways than one.
Have a good dinner.
I hope you guys, I feel, not gonna lie, I feel colder than
before.
This game actually, I think, cooled me down from the summer
heat.
Do you guys?
Do you guys feel like it cooled you down?
It worked.
I feel like I got over the summer heat a little bit.
There I go.
Thank you so much for the peek.
Thank you.
It's been great.
We're always melting our stress away.
The ice may have stopped you cold for a bit, but seems like
we may be at Elsa's castle now.
I know I'm excited.
Hope your dinner is super yummy.
Have a wonderful night.
You too.
Thanks for the stream, Vito.
This helped my burnout brain a lot.
I do feel a little cooler.
No burnout.
Happy Dendens.
You too.
Yes, but I turned on my AC.
It was totally the game.
The game made.
do you want to turn on your ac right right i'm freezing but
it's winter here oh sorry southern hemisphere sorry southern
hemisphere thank you guys so so much thank you for us for
the fun stream i hope you guys had fun too i will see you
guys when i see you next hopefully tomorrow or the next day?
No, no, not the next day.
Or whatever.
God, God, don't happen.
Thank you!
Stream is exactly what I needed to rest.
Good.
I'm glad.
I wanted it to be, like, a pretty chill stream, so.
Get it?
Oh, it's a week, though.
It's a week, though.
Everybody, thank you so much.
Have a good day.
I will see you later.
Bye-bye.
Bye-bye, bye-bye.
Bye-bye-bye.
Bye-bye.
you